un verano como ningún otro es el que
está viviendo eeuu debido a las altas
temperaturas y un sol abrasador que
azota al país de costa a costa
temperaturas de hasta 38.8 grados han
obligado a negocios de portland oregón a
cerrar sus puertas tanto para proteger a
los empleados como para desalentar que
los ciudadanos salgan a las calles y
wanna make civil queremos asegurarnos de
cuidar bien nuestros empleos y nuestra
comunidad y simplemente tratar de
mantener a todos lo más seguros posible
durante la ola de calor la gobernadora
cave brawn declaró el estado de
emergencia hasta ahora la red eléctrica
del estado ha soportado el choque sin
embargo han solicitado a la ciudadanía
reducir el consumo eléctrico en los
momentos más calurosos del día la
situación ha llevado a algunos
ciudadanos a repartir botellas de agua y
alimentos a personas vulnerables o sin
hogar tienen corazones de oro y creo que
debería haber más gente hacia los
efectos de la ola de calor se viven
incluso en la costa este temperaturas
similares se observaron en los estados
de nueva jersey nueva york donde también
temen fallos en la red debido al elevado
uso de aparatos de aire acondicionado el
país continúa luchando contra múltiples
focos de incendios según expertos
avivado por el calentamiento global
dixie en california es el segundo más
grande en la historia del estado